Smith humble assalamu alaikum peace be
unto you the seat is empty it's gonna be
full when our next guests coming up on
the Deen show one of the original guests
I'll have my jacket on I'm preparing
right now and we're gonna be reading one
of your questions and answer and get
here on the D show you better not go
anywhere
[Music]
[Applause]
we're back on the DG I told you were
gonna have the special guest one of my
original guests here on the Dean show
when we started back in 2006 shake yeah
sir are thee how are you I said I want
to come well a pleasure to be back come
they look like you aging too bad you
still look like I'm the original show
really much no I wish everybody else
said that also you're not noticing the
hair over here is kind of diminished
over the last five six years but hum did
thank you for finding the time it's
always a pleasure I look forward to if
the Creator the heavens ever given his
life to have you background the Dean
show pleasures mine comments all the
time is short and we want to get into
our first question I know this is a
sensitive topic but we get a lot of
questions from the not yet Muslims
mm-hmm and everyone has the potential to
submit to the crater yeah to do his will
and it's how you get paradise so Steve
is writing in but before we go to that
you've memorized the verbatim word of
god is this correct
alhamdulillah studying this is this
beautiful way of life is now well I've
been studying Islam informally since I
was a teenager since I was 15 16 years
old that's four decades but
professionally and full-time I've been
studying Islam for the last 15 years
from Medina ROG ten years in University
of Medina was that you know I mean we
can even add years ago I'm just gonna
finish the PhD from Yale and child are
very soon so I mean actually technically
you can even say seventeen years I've
been studying full-time that's been my
full-time profession is to study Islam
so we like our brothers in humanity to
get the Islamic perspective to know like
what are these Muslims think Jared oh so
Steve is writing and he's saying look
guys okay this is I'm paraphrasing the
the email we get a lot of these look if
God created man to like woman and woman
to like man what's the problem if he
created some men to like men or women
alike moment what's your guys problem
with that mm-hmm why you guys so you
know against this yeah this is obviously
as you said it's a very these days is a
very sense
the topic and it is difficult to speak
out against what we consider to be
certain immoral actions because frankly
if we criticize homosexuality some
people equate this with blatant racism
that criticizing homosexuality is deemed
to be pretty much the same these days as
criticizing somebody for the color of
their skin and they think that this is
something beyond their control and our
perspective and the perspective of
pretty much well all of the Abrahamic
faiths once upon a time in the last
twenty years that's been changing in
Christianity and Judaism but still many
Christian movements and many Jewish
movements and mainstream Muslims by and
large they still follow these
Commandments that they believe were
given by their creator by Allah by God
and of those commandments is that our
Lord has told us that sexuality is that
now this is our position sexuality is an
innate desire that's legitimate that is
permitted that is completely allowed to
enjoy within the confines of marriage
right we don't view sex and sexuality as
being something inherently negative or
evil there were some Christian
theologians such as st. Augustine and
others they actually viewed the sexual
urge as being inherently evil even
within marriage and they said that there
should be minimal pleasure even within
marriage that the only reason you should
procreate is for children but in our
religion we have a very different
perspective we believe that our Lord
gave us the internal desire to eat and
drink and procreate right and every one
of these desires can be manifested in a
permissible manner and it can be
manifested in an impermissible manner
right so it's good for us to eat
but our religion tells us certain foods
are harmful to us it's good for us to
drink our religion tells us that alcohol
is harmful to us we should avoid it go
ahead and drink natural juices drink so
many beautiful things that God has
created even drink concoctions we have
made up right as long as they're not
harmful to us similarly when it comes to
sex and sexuality our Lord has
encouraged us our Prophet Muhammad SAW
some has encouraged us to get married
and he has encouraged
live joyful lives and that means that we
be very explicit here he wanted us to
have good healthy sexual lives within
marriage our religion is very explicit
about this point the Quran tells us that
our Lord has created us from male and
female and he has made for espouses from
the opposite gender so that we may live
in peace and in harmony and find love
and comfort in them and so the man finds
comfort and love in the woman and the
woman finds comfort in love and her
husband and within the confines of
marriage that is a beautiful that is a
that is a part and parcel of human
society when the family is safe and
sound society is safe and sound we
firmly believe the family is the
building block of society therefore
anything that harms the family in harm
society and that is why our religion
tells us that divorce is something that
really should be avoided as much as
possible we want to break families up
unless sometimes it happens they really
have to hand over the divorce well then
okay that's inevitable but the the basic
rule is that couples should be remain
married to each other for really for as
long as possible till they die and
families should find peace and happiness
within each other because when they are
happy Society will be happy so our
religion says extramarital affairs are
not allowed that a husband cannot just
go sleeping around with other women and
that's a very major crime in our
religion right now similarly our
religion also says that finding sexual
pleasures within the same gender is
something that is an unnatural
manifestation of a natural urge the urge
is natural what is the urge sex and
sexuality that's natural right our
religion says limit that sex and
sexuality to that which is conducive to
yourself and to society at large and
that is marriage suppose somebody says
but it's not my fault I don't find
pleasure in women my pleasure he's a man
he says my pleasure isn't the same
gender suppose somebody says that and he
says God created me this way our
response to this is personally I'm not
going to go into the philosophical or
the biological question of nature versus
nurture you know did God create man a
particular man to be gay or not frankly
I don't
no but I do know one thing that every
one of us has temptations every one of
us has desires every one of us has
temptations and desires that sometimes
are harmful to us our religion tells us
one of the jobs of our faith is to
protect us from those desires and
temptations that will harm us so bottom
line they give an example here so I'm a
man and I have no qualms admitting in
public and on TV that as a man I'm
attracted to beautiful women this is
part and parcel of being a man and I
think I would be safe in saying that the
large percentage of you know my fellow
men would agree with me that a beautiful
woman is a something that basically does
not allow you to concentrate you know
it's yeah there's our hand to that yes
no this is something that you know it's
human nature that frankly it is
ingrained in us if somebody were to say
God created us this way there's an
element of truth yeah okay now does that
justify me lusting after every single
beautiful woman on earth does that
justify me saying you know what I can't
help it I find every single beautiful
woman attractive you know
let me just ignore my wife and the
rights of my wife and let me go after
this lady and that lady and that lady
would anybody agree to such type of
logic another person will say these are
called kleptomaniacs I have you the urge
to steal right another person will say
look I have plenty of money but when I'm
just walking in the store and I can find
a something to stuff in my pocket
there's just this urge inside of me I
can't help it I just want to take it and
steal what if he says this to the court
of law and the judge and the judge said
well okay God created you to be a
kleptomaniac go ahead what if a mass
murderer says I can't help it these
urges come in me and I just want to kill
people
now I'm not equating murder with
homosexuality but I'm saying what if
somebody says this is an urge in me I
can't help it no you can help it the
urge might be beyond your control but
then you can cater to it by blocking it
or by channeling it in a permissible
manner one of these two things has to be
done okay so if I have a lust for a
woman that's not allowed for
to lust after well then I have to
control that urge and have to find
happiness within the confines of
marriage and that's what our religion
tells us to do similarly if a man lusts
after another man he has one of two
options either he and I and there are
people and I have met many Muslims like
this so nobody can tell me this is not
true cuz I have met people like this
either he does try to minimise this urge
and find happiness in women and this is
possible and it has happened or if he
really finds it impossible well then the
only alternative for him is to live a
celibate life nobody is forcing a woman
on him nobody's forcing him to get
married it's not it's not a ligature in
our religion but if he finds that his
urge is something that our religion
considers to be unnatural then there's
nothing for him to do other than to
battle that urge just like I have to
battle urges for women they're not
allowed for me just like the
kleptomaniac has to battle urges for
just like the alcoholic when he passes
by some alcohol and his doctors have
told her visa Muslim his faith has now
renewed he remembers how beautiful that
wine was he remembers how sweet that
taste was right just like a drug addict
just because he has the urge it does not
justify manifesting that hurt now having
said that it's a very important point to
make you being a homosexual does not
disqualify you from being a Muslim I
mean very explicit here just like
drinking does not disqualify you from
being a Muslim just like taking drugs
you can be a Muslim and take drugs you
can be a Muslim and be a homosexual but
we will tell this person what you're
doing is immoral according to the
teachings of our faith and Christianity
and Judaism
well that is mainstream interpretations
you know that even within Christianity a
lot of a lot of differences are
happening but yes made many conservative
Christians Orthodox Jews yes they also
feel the exact same right there we have
to go to break and we right back to
continue okay here with Sheikh Nasser
cardi on the
it's simple to understand Islam means
submission look at the word submission
not to yourself not to your desires not
to anyone or anything because at the end
of the day you get something you always
want more you get some weed you want
more you get some drugs you want harder
drugs you get a girl you want a nicer
girl you get a car you want a nicer car
you get a house on a nicer house we've
got so many precious by enslaving
yourself worshiping God loving God with
submission to the one who created you
and by worshiping going and seeking his
pleasure you get pleased
back here on the Deen show are answering
a question on this sensitive topic
homosexuality mmm-hmm it was called
Sodom ISM is this right well the the
that's the term that is mentioned in the
Bible yeah it's yeah but isn't these
days of course it's called homosexuality
you're coming out or being gay now we
know we we have love for all mankind
and so now someone comes to you and they
have this urge you mentioned something
earlier before the break that you've had
these situations well yes I give us a
paint a picture now someone come to you
says you know how you put the arm I mean
how does it work the guy comes up to you
or you know and he's like or is a woman
into email is it is it one-on-one and
what advice did you give what happened
well we have I've had many different
people come up to me some have been via
email anonymous email accounts are too
embarrassed to the jury or someone live
I've had one person come up to me live
and basically pull me aside and you know
happen so this person told me quite
frankly that they're struggling with it
they've never actually done it and
that's why they weren't that embarrassed
to come and tell me that they're
struggling with it right that this is a
problem that as long as they can
remember
they've always been attracted to the
same gender this is a man and equals I
have always been attracted to men and I
just don't find any attraction in women
you know and I don't know what to do and
my parents are looking for a wife for me
and what is there to be done so in this
particular case the brother was not
averse to women but he found more
attraction with men
and so this brother I mean I guess in
our vernacular we may be bisexual then
that sounds like he you know I have I
have corresponding with some people who
said that the thought of being with a
woman wants to make me you know make me
puke I just I can't imagine that right
that's being with a woman in that matter
that I just cannot imagine I feel
nauseous
it's just disgusting for me right and so
somebody like that perhaps we cannot
advise him to find comfort in marriage
right if that's the case but the brother
that came to me it was like I just don't
find the same feelings and emotions and
I don't know whether I should do with
this or not so in our religion we have a
beautiful way of communicating with our
Lord and that is called salata istikhara
as rather this tejada basically means
you say a special prayer and if
something is meant to be and it's meant
for your good you're gonna see something
you're gonna feel an intuition or
something's gonna happen where you will
see that's what's best for you right so
I told this brother that prayer is the
Hara that you know put your heart and
soul in you know this fiance that your
your parents are you know looking you
know for you had they had somebody in
mind and he knew her and so you know
think about it praise the hata see if
it's where it's gonna work for you or
not and in this particular case I know
that they got married and have another
together right now so I don't know if
he's still battling with those urges by
the way but they are together the couple
is still a nom de leur happily married
so what I'm assuming is that even if
that urge is still there he has learned
to control it or he's learned to
minimize it do you think this helps now
that everywhere you look
sex is promoted I mean nudity
pornography everything is out there I
mean you think this is I have a theory
but I'm not an expert I'm not a
psychiatrist I have a theory that the
level of promiscuity the the level of
nudity the pornography that is so
rampant in our society I feel that's one
of the many evil symptoms that has
caused one of the many evil
after-effects if you like is that it has
desensitized man to what generally he
should not be desensitized to and I
strongly feel this is one of the reasons
why in this culture particularly that
we're living in in this era that we're
living in we see the
trend on the rise that the natural is no
longer sexy and exotic and so we find
and that's why perhaps also certain
fetishes which would be very disgusting
or very against the human nature right
are also ink on the rice and that's
probably one of the main explanations as
well also the openness of sexuality like
even one generation even you know fifty
years ago look at this this own you know
the country that were in now I mean I'll
never you know I'll never forget I saw
I've seen in that famous comedy I Love
Lucy you all know I Love Lucy that you
know one of the classic comedies of the
40s and 50s right and Lucy was married
to Ricardo they were literally married
you know the the couple that appeared on
it right but they never showed them in
bed together no they actually had two
separate beds in her bedroom yeah right
that they deemed it to be too too
immoral right to to risk to to it's just
too indecent to show a husband and wife
fully clothed in bed lying down together
now can you imagine that people who saw
that show live are still alive right now
people who were sitting in that audience
right or who watch the show on TV when
it was aired you know on American
primetime some of them are still alive
right now as we speak
look at how radically this very country
that were in now our country because
this is our country has changed and
that's gonna have some reaction that's
gonna have some effects and in my humble
opinion one of those effects is that it
has led to a rise in promiscuity even of
a natural premarital extramarital and
also things that our religion would deem
to be unnatural what do you have to say
about this we know that Islam is based
on evidence and proof it's not something
that you jump in on blind faith or any
person who's sincere they look at it see
like this is from the crater it's not an
organized religion by man or men so now
we see that when you look into Islam if
you look at it in a holistic you see
that everything that God Almighty the
crater told you to stay away from it's
the best self defense system don't go
near her fornication don't go
here adultery don't go alcohol not even
sitting at a place where there's alcohol
right if you look at no gambling all
these things that are just destructive
to the human beings of society I mean if
you look at us now as human beings as
Muslims it's even a sin isn't it you
know looking at a man isn't it his thigh
even his thigh
yeah so in our religion we're not even
supposed to look at the nudity of
another man that's what I'm saying like
you go into a locker room some play the
managers butt-naked we we don't even
want to look at a man we're told to
lower our gates weird-lookin they're not
even looking at someone naked all these
preventive steps that you know can
hopefully got well in your connection
with the crater and help you fight these
tendencies off yes that's so one of the
things that I would advise all of my
Muslim brothers and sisters to do in
fact everybody out there is to have a
connection with Allah with the Lord with
the Creator because really the main way
you can battle these internal
temptations is to have a stronger urge
than those eternal to the internal
temptations and if your urge to please
your Lord if your urge to establish a
connection with the Creator is stronger
than your urge to satisfy your baser
instincts then you shall be able to
overcome these instincts and urges that
will lead to things that are gonna cause
you harm in this world and in the next
one so let's give them something
tangible something that they can start
doing now if you're not praying for his
basic things of his own connecting with
God if you're a Muslim I'll tell you
something you can do Muslim and
non-muslim raise your hands up to the
one who created just like that just
raise your hands up and say don't even
say a name cuz if you don't know his
name say o you who created me just a
plea to your Creator
o you who created me guide me to the
straight path guide me to the path of
those whom you love and take me away
from the path of those who have gone
astray and those upon whom your wrath
has descended take me away from that
show me the path that will lead me to
you that's the generic prayer a prayer
that every human being should make on a
regular basis we make it every day in
our Salah in our prayer because that's
the part I just translated the last
three lines of Souderton fatiha which is
the first surah
that every Muslim recites but I removed
the name of Allah and I said okay call
the one who created you because in the
end of the day it's not the names as
important it's the one that you're
calling and if you call your Creator
then you are calling the creator of the
heavens and earth and this is a generic
prayer that every single person of every
faith can use at any instance in their
lives that oh you who created me guide
me to the path that you love simple
enough simple anything you can't tell us
I mean if a person is being sincere be
he the fornicator the person has jumping
scandalously from woman to woman he's
not happy the person who's on drugs
imagine this you mentioned this before
one of our shows you might get that
momentary pleasure like the candy but
the poison and here you get that example
yeah it wasn't sweet it's a poison sweet
and you know what I don't even have to I
don't have to prove it to you every
single human being on earth knows that
these pleasures are temporary that you
can have as many sexual encounters but
inside you still feel empty that you can
drink and women knives and drugs and
steel and Forney you can do whatever you
want
but deep down inside there's an empty
shell you can have all the macho nests
and the bravado and show off if you or
if you're a girl be as sexy as you want
in front of the others but deep down
inside you don't feel good about
yourself you don't feel good about
yourself why because God didn't create
you to act this way to act like a
hedonistic selfish animal God created
you for a higher purpose and that
purpose is to know him and to worship
Him you got it started doing it right
now start asking start asking and we'll
be right back
to close it up here on the Dean show
it's like when did you think that you
had no purpose
are you worthless the value comes from
purpose your purpose in life is to
worship the Creator no worship your
desires himself not worship social
pressure the celebrity culture but
worship the thing that's much higher and
transcendent above and beyond by
worshipping God and seeking his pleasure
you get pleased so you have double
pleasure this is my family but he's
always been stubborn you started having
his problems getting up to fight one
night policeman told me come on get him
from the station one fight here another
fight there his physical beam was great
for his ego but it left him ng if
someone who Eddy in his youth they would
predict that he'd be dead and the
outside people looking in today this is
the man
everybody knew Eddie at any given moment
could have 70 women that are running
around the club looking like he did
things that he he pushed himself to the
ethical extremes that he could I have to
get out of this totally
[Applause]
right now at the end there was just a
boy it was a constant struggle there was
in her soul was broken at that moment
there was that emptiness in his eyes it
was a big round tennis that I think I've
ever really seen in his eyes I'm running
here running there and mainly I'm
running that way it was dr. Jekyll mr.
Hyde and he was struggling with that but
the effort was there there was a
conscious effort to make that switch we
better start talking to his back look at
him he's fine idea good guy this was the
reality it was dead lady's consequence
he wanted to start showing the slime to
spread it to the nominally well people
didn't know who I was but why why are we
doing this hands-on took you serious
you're living a dream 10 people were
just stubbornly resistant and I started
looking at you like you're you know from
outer space I have to be out there and
trying to convince people to be on the
show that the first episode of that show
aired I think that's when you saw the
full chlorination come into the home
these guys changed what's going on here
this is a machine no see someone change
to see their character changes to see
positive changes in their life it's a
sign of God back here on the D show and
we made a whole session episode on the
question that the person was asking and
you were explaining now that there's one
thing that's pleasing to the crater and
there's one thing following our lusts
and desires so now before we went to
break you can never be happy living that
life then hedonistic life in every
country exactly you have to have a
spiritual connection the way that I put
it is this way
feeding the body is never going to feed
the soul and the body is a temporary
abode the body is a temporary gift that
we're gonna have it until we die that's
it our body's gone what will remain
forever is
the soul and feeding the soul is what
gives you eternal life and how do you
feed the soul you feed the soul by
connecting it to its source and that is
the Creator you connect it to the
Creator the one who blew that spirit
into man you connect that soul how do
you connect that soul through
remembering him through worshiping him
through rituals and prayer through
glorifying and praising him and that's
why every single person when they have a
spiritual moment and they praise God or
they say how beautiful is this creation
they feel a connection you know you know
that that moment when you see the sunset
on a beautiful day or you're standing at
the beach and you see the sunrise or on
a cloudless night you see the full moon
or you see all of the stars right that
feeling of awe that raw spirituality
that there's got to be a greater purpose
that what am I in comparison to all that
is out there surely the one who created
all of this has a reason for creating it
right that feeling of spirituality it's
got to be satisfied and how do you
satisfy it by reconnecting to the
Creator and that's that barter now you
you you you submit yourself to God you
don't follow your lusts and desires and
you slowly you start to leave off these
things that you thought were good for
you but the end they brought destruction
and you will feel the pleasure pleasure
now instead of the pain yes you're gonna
feel a real pleasure because you might
take the the hit of the dope or the coke
and you feel good but later it's a big
side effect later it's gonna feel it's
gonna make you feel disgusted and you
know that now you're go and hook up with
with with someone you shouldn't be with
outside of marriage
either way it's emotionally painful it's
physically and most importantly it's
spiritually devastating when you do it
God's Way the Craters way you're doing
it the right way and there's a
fulfillment there and there's a
spiritual connection and you feel good
about yourself about life about living
you feel you feel you're doing something
right why because you're doing it the
way that your Creator told you to do it
so no matter what this person that
person out there has done right now is
their hope for them oh there's always
hope there's always hope in our faith
there's always hope there is hope until
the minute that you die there is hope
but there's got to be something
your site you have to make an effort our
prophet told us that he who takes one
step towards God God takes ten step
towards him he who comes walking to God
God comes running towards him this is a
something in our tradition that we
firmly believe that when we show
sincerity to our Creator when we turn
our face to him and we say o our Creator
I am weak help me I can't get to you
without you helping me get to you right
and that's the beauty of our faith that
direct connection that direct connection
we don't go through the Prophet Muhammad
the Prophet Jesus Jesus and Muhammad
came to teach us about that direct
connection right that these prophets
came and they said worship the one up
there I have no good in me only he is
good up there
write them down here nothing that we are
the one over here we are all creative
we're all created when none of us is
God's walking on this earth right so we
turn to the one who created us directly
and we call out to him in the language
that we speak in the manner that we know
and we ask him to guide us to the path
that he loves
before we close just briefly talked to
us about this warning real quickly that
the prophets came to warn people about
in the glad tidings and this inevitable
reality about the Day of Judgment mm-hmm
justice I mean we don't accept we
everyone wanted justice for Trayvon
remember Trayvon yeah man was just it
doesn't make sense that everything in
this light look you know the Hitler's of
the world would get away with the
murders that we're not going to be
accountable for our actions like briefly
touch upon us so we firmly believe that
every single prophet came with some
basic teachings and messages number one
is the existence of God number two is
that there is something called the day
of judgment and the purpose of the day
of judgment is to reckon every person's
life according to the good and bad that
they've done and number three is that
the message of the prophets to be
followed the law the theology so number
two is the day of judgment and one of
the evidences that our tradition teaches
us that there is a day of judgment in
the Quran God asks us that do you really
think the sinner and the righteous
person are going to live a similar life
do you really think the tyrant and the
saint will get the same ending in fact
in this world many times the tyrant
lives a better life than the saint
in this world the sinner seems to have
more pleasures or money outwardly
inwardly we know he's suffering but
outwardly he seems to live the life
whereas most of the people who are close
to God might live difficult lives
impoverished lives right so the Quran
tells us that one of the evidence is
that there is a day of judgment is that
every person will get what they deserve
because one of the names of our Lord is
the one who is just our Lord is the
ultimate one who is just the ultimate
being who is just and it is not possible
that somebody who does evil and sin
throughout his whole life will not taste
the consequences of that in the next and
similarly it's not possible that the one
who does righteousness and good and
lives a moral life will not taste the
rewards of that so the glad tidings that
all the prophets gave Jesus gave
Mohammed gave a Moses gave the glad
tidings is that the righteous shall be
the ones who will inherit the kingdom of
God that's paradise right and the
iniquitous the evil the vile the wicked
they will not get that blessing because
they didn't deserve it because they
didn't show a commitment they didn't try
to earn the blessings of God so why why
should God bless them beautiful
beautiful we have to go the show is over
I'd like to thank you very much for
pleasure to be with us and insha'Allah
God willing we'll see you again and
she'll show she'll thank you said I
money alaikum Salaam and that's it we
answered your question I hope you got to
benefit you see life revolves around
pleasing the crater before we meet the
crater so we can live according to our
whims and our fancies and our desires
and at the end Judgment Day
all the prophets they warned about
Hellfire they gave the good news about
paradise and worshipping only the
Creator the one God who created you
created me this whole universe and
everything in it not worshiping Jesus
not worshiping a man a woman a monkey
the Sun the moon no worshipping the
creator of all that exists so we'll give
you something to do some homework right
now you might have done all the sins
things that just blacken your heart and
you're sad and you're crying you know
you're not happy start asking God to
guide you ask him alone and he'll
facilitate a way you give us a call 1
800 662 Islam we'll see you next time
here on the Deen show be good do good
peace be unto you